alors la musique c'est très simple c'est
une perte à face et une perte et c'est
une lésion cérébrale ou l'absence de
développement de capacités musicales
elles peuvent être variées elles peuvent
toucher le rythme elles peuvent toucher
la mélodie elles peuvent toucher
d'autres aspects et nous on s'est
intéressés surtout mais le dire est ce
que vous allez exemple en taxi
[Musique]
est ce qu'elle vous semble correct oui
vous êtes pas musique assure
le monde
e
pour moi il y avait quelque chose qui
clairement clocher bombay c'est ça les
gens à musique
il n'entendait pas ils l'entendent pas
dans le cadre d'une note qu'il sort de
la gay parade mi temps c'est tout petit
c'est vraiment très très peu qui sort de
la gamme mais qui à notre oreille
la plupart des auditeurs mondiale ou non
quelque chose qui va pas mais ces
individus là non ils n'entendent pas les
petites différences docteur comme
admettons qu'ils entendent pas et c'est
fréquent on en trouve souvent de cgp ces
statistiques alors tout dépend de vous
allez mettre la frontière mais disons
mois j'étudie les cas extrêmes et c'est
de l'ordre de 2.5 pour cent la
population
est-ce que c'est des gens qui peuvent
aimer la musique écouter de la musique
chanter dans une chorale
c'est très variable en fait lewis est
vraiment un aspect qui nous intrigue
beaucoup c'est que on a des gens qui
vont fuir la musique parce que c'est
comme d'un bruit de casseroles ceux là
on les étudie même pas s'ils refusent
ils en souffrent beaucoup
parce que la musique est omniprésente
et puis la majorité des à musique qu'on
a étudié ça les indiffère ils
comprennent pas sa grâce pomme se joint
pas du tout mais alors mais vraiment pas
mal et pour eux aller à un concert c'est
comme assister un discours dans une
langue étrangère a vraiment ce qu'a
vraiment vraiment c'est incompréhensible
pour les non absolument pas c'est ça
c'est la majorité et puis on a quelques
uns qui sont mélomanes est vraiment mais
le manana qui a écrit tout un livre
lattier ses formes les aime la musique
est gamins qui sont musiciens qui jouent
de la musique
je ne sais pas possible non